ينقسم الشارع البريطاني بين متفهم
للاضرابات التي تجري في بريطانيا بين
الحين والاخر واخرين رافضين لها لما تتسبب
به من فوضى في البلاد
فاضراب مترو الانفاق الذي يجري اليوم هو
سادس هذا العام او يشارك فيه الالاف من
الموظفين بسبب خلافات مستمره مع هيئه
النقل حول رفع الاجور وتغيير مع شات
التقاعد
10 خطا لمترو انفاق لندن توقفت عن العمل
لمده 24 ساعه ما شاء الله حركه الناس منذ
ساعات الصباح الاولى ووضع نظام الحافلات
وسيارات الاجره تحت ضغوطن دفعت العديد من
الناس الى العوده الى منازلها
ورغم تفاهمي العديدين لما يعاني منهم
موظفو السكك الحديديه في ظل الاوضاع
المعيشيه الصعبه لكن الكثير من الناس
الذين تعطلت اعمالهم هم من ذوي الدخل
المتوسط والمحدود والذين يعتمد العديد
منهم على المواصلات العامه لكسب ارزاقهم
نعم
المترو للوصول الى صف الدراسه ولكن الان
انا مضطر للمشي 40 دقيقه ورغم ذلك ساتاخر
بالتاكيد
اكثر
الاضراب اصبح متكرره ماذا نفعل نحن انا
اعمل لحساب الخاص فواتير زادت ولا احصل
على المال
لكن الامر باتي يؤثر على العديد من الناس
خصوصا الموظفين
ازمه اخرى تضاف الى سجل البلاد المتكدس
بالازمات التي تعجز الحكومه عن حلها بينما
يؤدي تراكمها يوما بعد يوم الى نفاذ صبر
الناس سواء من قبل العاملين في قطاع النقل
او المستخدمين له من لندن اعرب عبد الحق
العربيه